here at 8 news now we've been hearing
from many of you about rent hikes and
the challenge to find an affordable
place to live in southern nevada state
and federal leaders say help is on the
way though and a program called home
means nevada is a start
building right upon blue diamond is the
same building these are apartments being
built for seniors with a lower income
congresswoman susie lee says the average
unit here on fort apache near blue
diamond will cost about 800 dollars
that's far below the average rent in the
las vegas area of about 1450. i think
all of us who serve the public
can remember many times during this past
year having seniors and low-income
families call us
complaining about seeing their rents
increase and not knowing what they were
going to do yeah that's like a movie
room congresswoman lee governor steve
sisselek and other federal and state
leaders visited the construction site to
reveal more about home means nevada the
governor saying 500 million dollars for
the program is the largest housing
investment in the state's history
affordable apartments like this are
being built and rescue money to help
people stay in their homes is available
getting just one more person just one
more person into a home or keeping one
more family in their home is what this
is all about he points to a shortage of
84 000 affordable units for nevadans the
more than 400 thousand people moving
here over the last decade and the median
price for a home of more than 450
thousand dollars housing is an immensely
complex issue
the state is looking for partners like
businesses and community groups to get
affordable housing projects going
pre-applications are being accepted
right now we have a link to that and a
link for renters and homeowners in need
of help at eight newsnow dot com